hi and you want to see a video that they
made
it's just four minutes
do you want to see a video that I made
Maybe let's even know
it's a it's about a refugees from
Eritrea came to Israel this weird guy
with a funny accent well that's his
people in the street is me eat them a
rose creator of satirical political
videos in which I get into character
and deal with the racism militarism and
other Pleasant issues I've always
believed that my videos could touch
people change their perspective and
maybe even make a change can you want to
see maybe a video that I made all I
needed is an audience a stage
then came YouTube this is what happens
when you give everyone a voice a chance
to be heard and a stage to be seen that
voice that thought it didn't matter well
it can start a movie
[Music]
your diplom is to give everyone a voice
with no agent an experimental body
artist
an alternative pianist and even an
oppressed people craving for change
YouTube's promise has swept us off our
feet he guys it's Jules DIY and today it
is my first ever video
[Music]
100 views my God that's big yeah
Google announced that they were buying
the YouTube website the CEO of Google
calls this the next step in the
evolution of the internet
what is happening to My Views they get
lower and lower and lower and lower so
what happened between us and YouTube
still have enough fans I need more that
YouTube has been deleting clips and
channels of war crimes done [__] YouTube
this is [__] today Terror inside
YouTube headquarters for YouTubers so
far is to shoot YouTube employees and
then kill himself we have a report of
subject with a gun they heard seven to
eight shots being fired a long time
before all this happened I started my
journey from a simple desire oh it's a
cockroach I just wanted to go viral on
YouTube
[Music]
girl and horse Great Bond
what the [__] so what the hell do
Millions see in this video of a woman
petting a horse
what was I missing
okay my videos were shown in museums and
in the news but in YouTube where I can
really make a change I'm a total failure
I have no impact
what do they know that I don't
[Music]
so take my bags and go on a global
journey to talk to viral video stars
find the secrets of viral success and to
become viral myself
take
took
the accent a very strong Israeli accent
you think you can help me think yeah
think thank you for meeting me I missed
the laws Mr Rose Mr rose rose
[Music]
do you know how do you bark like a dog
this is an american dog right an
american dog try to imitate that Ruff
[Music]
now with my fluid English and my endless
Charisma I'm going to break the internet
yo [__] I'm coming
like me without views it's like flower
Without Rain I will crumble so if you
broke the internet or made it on YouTube
please
contact me help me
[Music]
okay only 227 views but sometimes it's
the quality one of my viewers was a
legendary YouTube star who invited me to
learn his secrets
foreign
[Music]
so this view is the view from the film
yeah from The Double Rainbow video okay
so so I saw this video I shot it right
here well here yeah I start where it
starts where the video starts I'm
standing right there yeah well I'm
walking this way the whole video is
going the whole time when I get to right
here there's no tree and I see the whole
thing
that's the video whoa that's a full
rainbow all the way
double rainbow oh my God it's a double
whoa that's so intense
whoa oh my God oh my God oh my God whoa
[Music]
double rainbow all the way across the
sky oh my God
what does this mean I wasn't doing them
because I was famous or anything I was
just doing them because it's a safer
place to put my my my content it's also
a way for me to prove that the things
that I say are true because it doesn't
sound real
God touched me he knocked me when he
touched me he knocked me to the ground
and and then he started speaking to me
and threw me it was like I saw the
burning bush that was what the rainbow
was maybe God is not a God maybe God is
Google or YouTube no that's a tool that
God uses
to touch people YouTube yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
it's made me an icon in a meme in a
living legend and it just keeps going
like I'm like it's I'm getting more
famous
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I want to be like you yeah I want to go
well and to feel great about it well the
first thing is you have to not want it
yeah but they want it and your cat
outfit then it will never happen to you
okay just I want you to look in my eyes
yeah tell me if you see this viral seed
that is going to to go
foreign
you have to let go you have to not want
it I am doing it for God to serve my
fellow man and when you do that you
become very powerful
you affect Humanity's Consciousness from
now on whenever someone sees a rainbow
they're going to think of this right who
does that
God
okay listen
so the guy uploaded his video on January
2010. Yosemite yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
talking about Yosemite right nothing
happened
Jimmy Kimmel tweeted my friend Todd has
declared this funniest video in the
world he might very well be right and
actually just after
it became viral it definitely couldn't
happen without Jimmy Kimmel now whether
Jimmy Kimmel is God or not I don't know
but but Jimmy Kimmel is our gatekeeper
what was his gatekeeper so Gatekeepers
would be an entity an organization a
person that controlled information who
are the people that can start
manipulating and influencing and
controlling the information in order for
it to go viral every Network have
different leaders have different
Gatekeepers it's making my work easier
because the connecting God is not my
strong side I think it would be much
more easier for you to find those Jimmy
kimmels and make it viral because of
them
sociality isn't the voice of God or the
voice of the people it's manager
navigated by The Gatekeepers those
standing at the gates signaling right or
left to fame or into Oblivion next house
is the director of
um
[Music]
I'm looking for Ellen DeGeneres
did you look for a house yeah I'm
looking for a house I want to deliver a
message yeah does she know you're coming
yeah
all right
can I read you a letter and you can tell
me if it's good or bad and I want to be
in Ellen DeGeneres Show
so I'm leaving here later
dear Ellen my name is and I'm a YouTuber
from Israel I've been creating satirical
video for the past decade I wanted to
become a famous YouTuber but I'm but I'm
a failure oh yeah this too
please tweet my channel and I will be
famous for you it's just a tweet for me
it's matter of life for this
foreign
I think it's very sweet it's to the
heart it's good put it under the gate
okay I would pin the letter to the shirt
and put that up okay
I found some cat videos to prove that
cats can teach us things very very
important things for instance I watch
meaningless cat videos on Ellen's show
and I get it
even if she read my letter my political
videos had no chance
if I want to pass The Gatekeepers I need
to adjust to be less meaningful
so how can I try not to say anything
after 10 years of making political
videos how the hell will I create a
video without meaning so go back to the
video the 12 minutes this time as a
source of inspiration
maybe I will just copy it after all you
don't change a winning horse
let's go
upstairs
my wife offers to be the girl and find
me some animals now I just need a great
bone
all right
foreign
[Music]
after spending a decade in making my
political videos a 22 second video
bypass everything I did easily
The Secret of reality not to say
anything
you cannot argue with facts
it turned out that the Great Bond
between Anna and the goat moved hundreds
of thousands in India Pakistan and Saudi
Arabia I'm not a racist all clicks were
born equal
I stare at the rising numbers with a
message or without I need more I need
Millions it's time to take out the heavy
guns my biggest viral asset Michel my
sweet son
after getting more than 2 million views
I continue with my motto if you cannot
understand them copy them
I realized that people uploaded all the
home videos to YouTube for everyone to
see share the child's phone
share the touching lullaby and even you
can become a viral star
[Music]
so try with Michel all kinds of viral
combinations
laughs
[Laughter]
Michelle disappoints me instead of
spitting the lemon he swallows it
eagerly
Nissan
videos maybe he's more into politics
like me I show him historical and
political figures
foreign
[Music]
with no explanation really in a face
that you like immediately that just
makes you happy when you see it
[Music]
as a father it was hard to say that
nihal is a self-eating Jew but for the
sake of the experiment I follow his
heart's desire
[Music]
okay baby
I upload baby Hitler's video it gets
decent views and Sparks it today
but it still doesn't get me to the next
level
so you visit one of the top viral kids
to get some tips
how did it go
[Music]
yeah kind of felt good didn't it
is this real life yeah this is real life
okay now
now I I have two fingers
stay in your seat
why is this happening to me it's okay
bud it's just from the medicine okay
forever no no it won't be forever
this becomes one of the most legendary
viral videos of all time David after
dentist you know that video you were
gonna launch one of the most successful
viral videos of all time David put that
down I feel funny why is this happening
to me I can't see anything stay in your
seat
[Applause]
[Music]
he just was back in this was 2008. we
didn't have a YouTube channel or
anything like that the only reason he
put the video on YouTube was so he could
get the link
to send it to the family that was the
only intention and then Sunday we looked
at it and it was uh 10 000 views and we
were like what's going on and we never
send it to anybody we didn't send it to
one person and then like Tuesday
Wednesday or Thursday it was somewhere
between three and four million views but
we were like worried like we're like
what's why did this happen and you know
weave inside of taking it down people
told you about the video when you oh boy
they wanted to call the police they
wanted to put me in jail and this is oh
I'm very serious you can understand why
some people think that's exploiting the
child not good for him can you it's been
a very it's been a very positive
experience for our family uh why has it
been positive what's positive about it
tell me what the positive is it's put
them through private school and and
we're hoping that it'll pay for some of
David's or all of both boys College
that's what we're hoping we kind of it's
found money like winning the the lottery
so we can't complain too much he doesn't
need
you know if you feel it changed you no I
still think I'm the same
but I mean I've never really lived
where I wasn't famous off a YouTube
video and then what do you want to do in
your life you have an idea psychology
like the chemical reaction to the brain
though that's interesting to me like
when people go insane like what happens
in their brain that makes them go
insane stuff
I believe that David's family would have
removed the video if they didn't earn
all that money from YouTube
[Music]
YouTube updated the dream and offered
everybody the chance not only to be
famous but also to get rich from the
intimate family moments
the parents around the world chased the
dream started documenting their kids
looking for those dramatic situations
when the head you'll be fine
you'll be fine okay I see you when they
cry
out
lie I can't feel my mom away
when they're operated
ouch also recreate David's success
and so even an abdominal operation for a
small child has become a play begging
forward clicks you said you want me to
put this on YouTube right
[Music]
foreign
clicks that are worth a lot of money for
YouTube
on Monday Google announced that they
were buying the YouTube website for 1.65
billion dollars our next guess is a big
reason why
[Applause]
[Music]
one two
so I I hear you want to be a
YouTube celebrity
yeah or Star so what is better to be
personally for me it's better to be a
star because you don't have to continue
to put out that content but YouTube they
don't want somebody like me anymore
they don't they don't want a video One
video that gets 300 million hits
they want somebody that produces 300
videos that all get a million hits each
because at the end of the day YouTube is
a business and they make money by
linking up advertisers with audiences
and so if you have a person that's 300
videos that has a million hits on each
one they have an audience of a million
around a million people and they know
how old those people are they know how
much money Their audience makes they
know where they live and they go to
advertisers and say oh you're targeting
13 to 16 year old girls who live in a
family of four and their parents drive
this type of car okay perfect we have
this person who makes videos and that's
exactly who watches their videos they're
driven by their advertising Revenue
bye Please Subscribe
[Music]
its business model they promote and turn
into Styles those who produce a lot of
content on a regular basis Again YouTube
updated our Dream No More Counting views
from now on WE count subscribers
really need
to subscribe
the same change in the business model
led to the rise of genres and channels
and created a new class of YouTubers I
tried to open toys and becomes the
youngest millionaire in the world a
transsexual who makes makeup tutorial
and sells products that was the full
drugstore look oh a Swedish guy who
earns Millions by playing computer games
but the big change focusing on channels
and subscribers also gave a boost to
different and unique voices a political
blogger Democratic socialism versus what
is social democracy a vegan Iranian with
five YouTube channels videos
who does not answer to anyone not even
to the American Army in which itself let
me tell them what you did in the desert
someone that Millions like to hate but
nobody can ignore kill everyone inside
and call ourselves Patriots in short a
role model for me but if it was your
family I'm sure you wouldn't be so
thrilled so you're saving him down me
and then you became a YouTuber what is
the story
um when I was in the Air Force we had
this this meeting this big Hall and they
asked everybody why they joined the Air
Force they said college and everybody
raised their head almost everyone you
know most everyone was there for
themselves and the whole patriotism
thing was uh nonsense and uh Americans
that I'm serving with are pricks
[Music]
so I didn't like that it was draining
and it was depressing and I wanted to be
part of the world that I admired and so
I wanted to get into the American
YouTube Community or just the YouTube
community in general that's when I
started making videos
[Music]
this was really exciting for me because
I didn't really have an outlet for that
kind of creativity
[Music]
not a lot of stuff happened until I was
featured on the main page of YouTube one
day I'm a banana you're a what I'm a
banana what happened to your clothes
who deals with political content and
doesn't give them about anyone hit
YouTube's top page only with a song
about a banana
and even a Sim the radical vegan
activist realized that for YouTube to
expose her to a new audience she needs
fake boobs
so if you want people to see my
political videos I also need to make
thousands of videos and occasionally
flick it with a viral song
so I make my way to meet two YouTubers
that figured out the formula hey guys
hey need
building a targeted Community around the
channel
if someone can make even a call like
missing it's them for there
[Music]
and Chrissy
I always say that if you want to be a
successful YouTuber and you really want
to blow up then you have to find
something that hasn't been done or
something that's been done and do it in
a different way like for us there were
other LGBT content creators there were
other lesbians online making videos
there was no one that was doing it and
singing where the singing lesbian Duo of
YouTube yeah yeah and you whatever it is
you have to find your Niche I think your
talking shirt idea is really great
really something
hi I'm a failure on YouTube my name is
itama Rose make the mouth a little bit
and maybe make it a little positive yeah
but I'm going to be the most famous
YouTuber in the world
I think that's a really great idea it's
a hit let's have your shirt sing a song
watch the magician see a star I think on
the B you should go wild yeah
[Music]
it was good below is good
you like that yeah one two be a star one
to be a star
great
I am a talking shirt
no one watches me dead depressed desert
for Success leave to watch me like me
share me and hug me subscribe me
thanks to Brian Chrissy I've made my
first step as a YouTuber I found my
uniqueness
but this is only the first step so they
learned back in the 50s and 60s and 70s
that celebrities
sold products and they're finding that
YouTubers have huge influences over
their audience more than the regular
definitely more than regular celebrities
because they've they've grown to trust
them they've grown to feel connected you
know you meet George Clooney or another
Brad Pitt Angelina Jolie these huge
movie stars
we like them we see them on screen but
we don't feel connected to them but a
YouTube person who you see the
day-to-day life that they live it feels
almost like a friend our Vlog channel is
definitely our die hards they want to
see what we're doing every single day
they're tweeting us all hours of the day
commenting on every photo they've been
with us through ups and downs and so
these people for for them we are like
family almost good morning so I just had
to go get a filling I was leaving and I
stopped by this coffee shop to get some
water so if this is my life even I can
my life is no less boring than those of
the most successful YouTubers there's a
washer right here inside this building I
can do it at least once a day I'm
brushing my toes
when I was young my parents didn't
insist
that I will brush my teeth then I have a
lot a lot of holes
as you can see they have you some blood
it's better not to learn for me how to
do it but I want you to know me better
and to know that I have a lot of
problems with my taste
and I'll see you in the Vlog tomorrow
friends
how is it to be a YouTuber how is it to
make it your life the game
decisions but the but the upside is
ever stop working keep feeding the Beast
constant so you must be the best yeah
six videos a week six videos no and
you're not serious no yeah serious like
if you now want to stop for your child
and you want to start for three months
what will be our career would disappear
it would disappear no we know it would I
know it would
so who is this terrifying Beast that
Brian Chrissy have to feed with six
videos a week what is an algorithm an
algorithm is essentially we're just
being the piece of the code on YouTube
that decides what video should be
ranking where in the list for what
that's it how much tuning to the week in
order to uh it's a minimum of three
videos it's generally three videos is
generally considered the minimum for the
algorithm not to hate you so now I
understand why every YouTuber also makes
Vlogs it's not for us the audience but
mainly because that's what you can
produce easily daily to satisfy the
beast's appetite
so I decided to go 24 7 and shot my
whole life with the head cam
with the amount of videos I upload I can
call myself a proud YouTuber but I still
feel my subscribers count can do better
two I was an alcoholic
Uber
I started losing their virginity in
seventh grade here's how he started
calling me nicoto avocado
it's not enough to share only the daily
stuff I need to let go of my protections
show my subscribers who I really am yo
friends
today some serious stuff it's very
personal
I have serious problem with my wife from
the moment the baby was born
she don't give me any attention and I
feel completely alone I have no sex at
all even at once maybe you can give me
some Digital Love instead something like
1 000 views it's like having sex with
her do it for him it's so sensitive I'm
naturally can handle a divorce please
share comment like keep the smile on
[Music]
YouTube space I am right outside YouTube
space Tokyo YouTube space Dubai
after reaching 207 subscribers by
sharing my full sex life I feel ready
professional YouTubers those who create
daily content and build a noticeable
Community are invited to YouTube space
which provides state-of-the-art
equipment and fancy Studios for
Youtubers with more than 5 000
subscribers [__] I don't have 5 000
subscribers I turn to Google YouTube's
father to help me deceive his naughty
son I follow Pages offering to sell
likes views and followers and finally
reach the phone called blackheads a
place where view dealers click from
owners and hackers manage the Dark World
Behind virality
I found one of the top hackers
he lets me film only with his face
covered
I'll guess he'll want some likes some
comments some dislikes you can fix all
of it of course without it it won't be
believable what you have to do is just
copy the URL of your movie
you paste it here
then you copy this list you paste it
down here whoever is online will
immediately watch the movie I'm not sure
because every YouTube clip that has many
millions of views started that you say
even Justin Bieber is used everybody I
remember when Gangnam Style got started
me and my colleagues were all very busy
telling me big news for me that like
Gangnam Style is based on fake view the
first Millions were fake for sure
YouTube sometimes identifies it and
sometimes it does why they're not
fighting till the end YouTube itself is
also being measured somehow they don't
want to fight the fake views because it
will influence their number too much
where will YouTube be without the fake
fuse 400 short but with an army of 5 000
Russian subscribers I'm inside the
YouTube space
with my Hebrew political videos having
thousands of Russian fans maybe dakir
had a point about the motivation of
YouTube to fight the phenomenon
foreign
a huge star in the Arab world who
creates videos dealing with racism in
the approach to Islamic
hit her again and I'll call the cops
this was my chance to see a large budget
YouTube production what does my mom say
welcome to another edition of fan video
responses and we have a question today
from hey fam what Russell or this
equipment for just another Vlog from the
couch possible what's up Ethan we're all
cool and I want to know is how to be
confident on myself okay first off I
want to just say
um it's it's confidence confidence can
always be worked on and the you know the
wonderful thing about this world is that
it's not all about beauty if you're
worried about how you look I mean look
look at me I got I'm balding man I'm
balding so I would imagine that you know
it makes me less beautiful but in
reality beauty is not always how you
look so think you hate them Habibi and
I'll see you next time peace loving
unity and see you later
okay
so that's one video thank you
so you're like a psychologist of uh kind
of millions of people yeah yeah I know a
lot of people who sit online watch TVs
they don't have anyone you know they
what they spend a lot of their time on
the internet so they feel alone so
that's why they connect with a lot of
YouTubers so I have to give back in a
way and uh this is how I give back you
know talking to them one by one
so being a YouTuber isn't only talking
about your life but also listening to
millions of fans providing a shoulder to
lean on in tough times
okay fans all over the world after you
heard my stories it's time for me to
help you the first question is from
mabuto from central Africa a hi itama I
love your videos thank you and I have a
problem in my Village we have no water
some of the family members died
I'm very very thirsty what to do
have only one thing to say to you water
is just another material don't be so
materialistic you know I need water I
need food be more spiritual you need to
ask yourself
who is the real mabuto to think about
your self-confidence to believe it
yourself to be authentic even if you
need to die die as yourself die is
mabuto keep it real be part of my gangs
stay in touch love you mobuto
see you later
so after saving my bottle from dying
it's time to meet my fans face to face
so you go with friends and YouTubers
meet off screen
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I realized that everybody is walking
around with expensive cameras shooting
Vlogs and I can't figure out where the
YouTubers and World defense
[Applause]
[Music]
and I'm 16 years old wow you can really
dance I have 40
000 subscribers on YouTube any
Adventures
[Music]
important
results
[Music]
with all kinds of uh companies I have
Adidas they give me clothes and money
and for that I I post on my blog with
their clothes I sell in two weeks 10 000
t-shirts
I was like whoa are you serious that's
my power
oh
when I see a teenager selling tens of
thousands of shirts I understand it's an
industry so I'm off to a convention open
to the YouTube industry only where they
make things happen
[Music]
ing
but I wasn't getting brand deals wasn't
making money I got to the point that I
don't use like anything like that
everything's like light hard I try not
to swear in my videos so it's kind of
building that foundation and then kind
of like changing again to fit Brands so
I'm on a level now where Brands will
work for me if you don't know how our
website makes money it's because you are
the product they're selling you to
advertisers right my selfie cam the new
YouTubers understand that the audience
is the product they sell to the
advertisers rf35 excuse me yeah
you're from Nestle yeah yes I heard the
talking for I'm items I'm a YouTuber
it's about foreign
I feel that I can be very good YouTuber
for your brand all right well tell me
how would you sell one of our products
okay in 911 okay and I saw the building
collapsing yeah
I knew some guy that died
Uncle Jimmy
laughs
I must relax
yeah I can't go back to my management
and say I've got to find a great blogger
who's talking about death and then
Resurrection through Nescafe I need to I
need branding that is but you need from
happy to Happy Well maybe it's funny to
but it just can't be death to have to to
bran
have a break have a kit kat can you work
with that oh my God oh my God Uncle
Jimmy
I have to take a break
foreign
is in charge of matching us to the
client to the advertisers algorithms
like when no one knows what it is yeah
besides the actual like it's like a
puzzle and when you get close to work
and how it changes yeah we'll reach a
point where an algorithm a code an AI
analyzes every single frame of your
video and the audio track of course we
will in the middle of the mingling
algorithm OG of YouTubers and
advertisers I'm glad to see there are
still some alternative creators making
different bizarre art
response
welcome back to
another
relaxing
our video ever made
part
six
so if I will do it using it it can help
me succeed in YouTube yesmr videos
usually watched from start to finish
because the person will want to fall
asleep too and try not to YouTube
algorithm Works based on how long a
video is being watched so if you have
100 of watch time on your videos you
will immediately push you to the top of
the algorithm what a disappointment she
Whispers not to us but to the algorithm
listen to to help you fall asleep we we
actually used to be a hub for all the
weirdo children that just wanted uh that
just wanted to seek comfort and dive
into their art that nobody else out
there accepted and now it just feels
like every every third kid is in it just
for the money and just for the business
that's not that's not the honest
platform I Used to Know
I like to say that there have been four
generations of YouTube and we are in the
the generation that is now grew up with
YouTube as a part of their childhood
YouTubers I'm calling them they saw the
success of PewDiePie making his millions
remember to subscribe if you haven't
already they saw how these platforms can
be star makers and now they're seeing it
as their opportunity to launch their own
personal brand or their business
already knew which side of YouTube's
bread was buttered people like me are
not good for big businesses the
generation that was born to sell then
YouTubers
always nice to see highly motivated kids
even the conventions organizers weren't
comfortable about the Nets effect on
kids so they bought an expert and so I
have the pleasure of running the largest
Center in the world of its kind focusing
on the relationship between young people
and the media we want to focus a lot on
the positive effects of media so let's
keep that in mind as where we want to go
in the next 40 to 45 Focus only on the
positive I would like a great start for
a balanced academic discussion
definitely see so many incredible
opportunities of media for young kids so
I've seen effects on positive effects on
literacy language math science
engineering so we can all relax our
children can serve as long as they want
it will make them successful it's
scientifically proven
it's okay like the situation yeah it's
not it's not nearly as
um problematic as our popular rhetoric
or our media as our general lay
conversation might suggest a little too
convenient I felt as if I'm talking with
Youtube CEO so ask her about it how much
time you are the manager of the place
um about four years I guess of the
director of the particular Center I've
been there exfolios you had some
partnership or some fun I've done some
collaborative work and in those with
each care companies um I would not talk
about them on air but because I don't
want to cause any problems for any of my
companies I will never find out the real
story because just after our talk the
festival director kicked me out claiming
that I was asking unprofessional
questions
I am talking sure
[Music]
the moment I ask a critical question I
was kicked out
[Music]
apparently on YouTube it was happening
on a much louder scale YouTube
Advertiser boycott started about five
days ago after some ads from Big
corporations showed up in front of
inappropriate content but the reaction
has been countless advertisers
threatening to or actually pulling out
their money from YouTube hundreds of the
largest companies from Coca-Cola to
Mercedes have threatened to boycott
YouTube and respond to the fact that
YouTube has put their commercials next
to violent and racist content like Isis
videos
so YouTube decided to play it safe they
stopped showing ads not only in Isis
videos but in many videos millions that
were out of consensus not pleasant that
the algorithm profiled is not brand
friendly
as you know the past year we've been hit
with YouTube's mass demonetization of
LGBT channels so we got engaged we are
obviously super excited about it we
uploaded the video and within two
minutes the video was demonetized we
couldn't figure out why the video was
pretty PG except that it said future
wives in the title or maybe because it
was two women YouTube went to [__] then
we went through other videos and I found
out there was like a hundred of our
videos that were demonetized for really
ridiculous reasons one of our videos are
proud to Love video that YouTube
actually reached out to us about four
years ago in make the video in an email
and said we would love for you to make
this video showing what it's like to
love another woman and now YouTube has
demonetized it for we don't know what
the reason is what they do is they
literally look at the title they look at
the thumbnail and they say is this even
remotely whatsoever uh something that
could potentially be problematic as a
comedy satire Channel why am I getting
killed why we removed our Wall Street
Journal video so political no money is
YouTube over about the Wall Street
Journal political no money Muslim
Edition about religion controversial
very controversial not ad friendly
demonetized smile more and be happy just
don't express your opinions Guys YouTube
became the Big Brother whoa sees and
overhears everything don't talk about
being gay
don't talk about being
r-e-l-i-g-i-o-u-s don't talk about
p-o-l-i-t
never talk about your own belief
otherwise you will be discriminated and
censored YouTube is a political actor it
has interest and it exercise power there
is no information that is neutral there
is no technology that is neutral
revenue on half of my videos so that's
like fourth four thousand videos divided
by two so two thousand videos I lost ads
on which means I just got like half
fired we are at a loss at this point and
we just don't know what to do they fired
a lot of people they went from having a
job to having a hobby I have been
putting all of my money into this
Channel and my survival basically for
the last five years and I am probably
going to lose my home because of it so I
am just
Beyond
saddened and frustrated that I could not
continue to support myself that way it's
really painful to see people lose their
jobs their home their life's work
but I can understand YouTube's decision
to please the advertisers after all it's
business
but the more research the less it makes
sense YouTube Not only prevented ads
like the brands asked for but hid and
even deleted millions of videos and
channels
so I wanted to talk to you about a video
that YouTube took down it was upsetting
when the video got deleted and I'm
pretty sure they deleted it for a reason
that was probably a misunderstanding
they ate restricted my app workout video
well I did that because this is what
they are doing to weekend activists does
YouTube hate LGBT content creators I
mean that's a really intense statement
so if it wasn't for the advertisers why
did you delete millions of videos
including videos documenting war crimes
an effort to protect viewers from
violent videos YouTube has been deleting
clips and channels showing atrocities in
Syria in some cases those videos may
have been the only evidence out there of
war crimes activists worry without this
video proof crimes may go unpunished so
maybe they made their big move to clean
up YouTube from everything that distract
us from our only Destiny consuming
about economic incentives that's
worrying I'm worried about political
incentives where particular partisan
incentives are being played and we don't
know that or is it political did they
wipe out millions of videos from
conflict zones to show the leaders of
huge markets like China and Russia that
they don't need to worry about Russian
spring or Chinese spring happening in
YouTube ever again the revolution will
not be utilized I literally cannot put
into words how angry I am this is
[__] what is certain is that they
made this huge move without providing
explanations to the public to the
millions of YouTubers woke up to
discover that their life's work was
ruined I asked YouTube a direct question
I said what do I need to do to get my
channel off of your Blacklist
and they sent me an automated response
and as some of you know I've gotten
billions of views on YouTube okay that
equates to millions of dollars for
YouTube I have paid
lifetime salaries no doubt of certain
YouTube workers
and they can't even give me a response
that is human today Terror inside
YouTube headquarters
subject with a gun they heard seven to
eight shots being fired we have four
victims who have all been transported
for gunshot related injuries senior law
enforcement officials tell NBC News the
suspect is a woman in her mid-30s and
multiple law enforcement sources tell
NBC News she died at the scene the
identity of the shooter Nasim Ogden she
shot a man and two women before taking
her own life growing on YouTube is not
in your hands
it all depends on who is controlling
your Channel
a few hours after the shooting The Sims
videos were deleted from the web
she was wiped off Collective
Consciousness as if she never existed
yeah a lot of people are for the
argument that you know it's a private
company and you know we shouldn't have a
big say in anything that goes on
yet at the same time we're talking about
a monopoly people have to step in and
make sure that this company isn't
deciding the fate of the entire economy
or our society and right now YouTube is
deciding the fate of our society in many
many ways it's a centerpiece of our
society and should be treated as such
and essentially owned and operated by
the
the overall community and not just by a
few people who are
working in the best interest of a dollar
[Music]
really good
look at these moments all of these
stories Secrets Revelations from every
corner of the world
[Music]
foreign
I would have liked to tell you that
after everything that happened I took my
faith into my own hands left YouTube and
took my heart back to the streets
but in real life as YouTubers that
invested many years and most of our
money can't really leave YouTube
our Channel belongs to them our
subscribers are Theirs to keep we cannot
take anything
YouTube is their tube
you're not citizens we are just subjects
without property without basic rights
[Music]
santilly changes and will make YouTube
great again I'm here on the street with
my gang yeah
please
foreign
[Music]
so my last advice is keep it real unless
it's the blessing be authentic if you're
not gay or something strange and raise
your voice unless you're Syrian
and don't be heavy take it easy buy
yourself some nice stuff and everything
will be okay
foreign
about YouTube Just because I couldn't
become viral so I have a video of my son
who can easily break the internet
but you know the internet in the Middle
East with all the walls is very weak and
anyway my computer is broken now
but believe me it can easily get 100
million views
[Music]
thank you